hey what's up Samuel leaves here and in
this video I wanted to talk to you about
passive income and the five ways you can
make passive income through property so
before I tell you where you can make
passive income from in property let me
just explain to you what passive income
is because most people they're not talk
about passive income if you know what it
is is because you're self educated
because I mean in the in my book buy low
rent high which by the way if you've not
read you really should read this I say
when I was at school if I'd have told my
teachers that I wanted to be a property
investor they would have said that it
was risky they would have told me that
if I wanted to guarantee success I
needed to follow their system and I'm
sure you're familiar with their system I
call this the seven lies because all my
life probably all your life we were told
by the government by our school teachers
by our parents this sort of stuff I call
this the seven lies one study hard at
school as it's important you get good
grades to go on to university if you
want to be paid well three get a good
job for life four if you buy a house pay
off the mortgage as quickly as possible
five save as much money as you can to
store away safely in the bank six the
harder you work the more money you make
and seven look forward to retirement
because that's the good life you've
probably heard that that is such
nonsense that is the opposite of passive
income that is the opposite of financial
freedom that's called being a slave to a
job forever and we know what a job
stands for jump out of bed on a journey
of boredom to be just over broke working
forty hours a week for 40 years to
retire on 40% of what we couldn't afford
to live on in the first place to begin
to get your mind around the new way of
thinking which is passive income which
is financially freedom I'd say these are
the seven truths one most people do not
benefit from good school grades oops
maybe I shouldn't have said that maybe
you're offended right now but hey this
is this is it to most people who finish
University still struggle to get a job I
know so many people who went I invested
in myself and went to start down on
property courses I'm like 17 18 years
old they
de menthe they went to university and
and after finishing University after
four years of spending like fifty
thousand pounds on university they
couldn't even get a job it's sad but
it's true number three a good job for
life doesn't exist for paying off the
mortgage quickly is not smart so if your
money is shrinking in the bank six some
of the poorest people are the hardest
workers I know that because I've been
out in the slums of India and the rural
parts of Africa and seven if retirement
is your motivation you will be extremely
disappointed what is passive income
passive income is when you work once and
you get paid forever active income is
when you work once and you get paid once
therefore you have to keep working to
keep getting paid you're trading your
time and your energy you're trading that
for money
whereas passive income do something once
invest in something months and you're
getting paid on going when your passive
income equals your living expenses
you'll financially for it
not necessarily rich but you don't have
to work again and again because your
passive income covers your lifestyle so
there's different ways to make passive
income you can make passive income from
from network marketing from automated
online affiliate schemes and all
different things vending machines
advertising spaces there's different
ways to make passive income but I
believe that the best way to make
passive income is through property
investing or if you're in America real
estate why is that it's because it's
bricks and mortar you can touch it you
can feel it not only does it give you an
income a passive income but also you've
got an asset that's going to appreciate
over time so that's why I love property
so much also if you go on the Sunday
Times Rich List you'll see that all the
people that are rich that are making
good money they all invest in property
there's a common denominator and it's
property so here's the five ways that I
make passive income from property and I
think you should be too number one is by
to let life delay it's just simply when
you buy residential houses family homes
and you rent them out people always need
to live in them you will always get an
income from them and that is called
buy-to-let property investing it's
fantastic it's very bread-and-butter
number two is HMOs if you want to lift
the cash flow a little bit
great way to earn passive income that's
when you rent a house of Multiple
Occupation out so you rent out an a
room-by-room basis to young
professionals or to students you get a
higher income with the right management
systems in place that is a very very
healthy form of passive income number
three service accommodation of them
videos about serviced accommodation you
can check them out just above serviced
accommodation is almost like a hotel
with no staff it's when you rent out a
property an apartment a house but you've
rented out a serviced accommodation on
things like air B&B rocking calm you
have guests instead of tenants now this
needs to be managed and system was
properly otherwise it's not passive
income but when it is managed and
systemized properly it will give you
probably the highest form of cash flow
and passive income that any of the other
strategies will give you service to
combination it's a minefield you need to
get the right training to do properly
but it's a fantastic way that we make
very very high passive income number
four commercial property we invest in
commercial properties I'm just in the
process of buying a 1.5 million
commercial unit at the moment the great
thing about commercial property is
there's a real tax advantages to buying
commercial you save on stamp duty you
can buy it through a SAS so your pension
can invest in property also the tenants
are usually very very long-term they'll
sort of 15-year leases and they will be
responsible for the maintenance of the
property so it's completely passive I
would recommend probably starting out
with residential but once you've got a
nice property portfolio already
definitely start considering commercial
lastly is a property business you could
set up a sourcing company which is where
you find properties and pass them on to
investors people say the problem is of a
sourcing company is its active income
you make massive income but not passive
income because you can find a property a
day and pass it to an investor or make 3
grand a day William but it's active true
until you turn it into a business which
is when you have staff some people are
really scared of staff oh my gosh I
wouldn't want any staff listen if you
want to get very wealthy you want to be
able to have the lifestyle but you can
do what you want when you want with who
you want then there's nothing wrong with
having staff again do it properly make
sure the right contracts and you do
properly built if you have a property
business and you
staff is true passive income and it can
be passive and massive but first steps
is to become financially free before you
stop thinking about taking on loads of
staff how do you become financially free
read the Box attend the classes in the
seminars and implement the knowledge we
run a two-day property investors crash
course if you've not been to the
property investors crash course that is
where it always starts I mean I have
success students every single week
people were leaving their jobs becoming
financially free turning into property
moguls and all of them all go through
the property investors crash course so
you can again in the description you can
book on to the property investors crash
course and guess what it's completely
free I don't know how long are we
continuing to run these crash courses
for free but it's completely free people
traveling from all over the world so
claim your free ticket today and I look
forward to seeing you on the next video
thank you so much
[Music]